ist das Erbe von Wolfgang Schäuble heute
stärker in der CDU als das von Angela
Merkel das müssen andere wirklich Werten
ich glaube wir haben beide unsere
Beiträge geleistet und schauen Sie auch
bei Friedrich Merz ist ja nicht so ich
habe seine
wirtschaftsfanzpolitische Sachverstand
den habe ich immer geschätzt wir hatten
da auch manchmal unterschiedliche
Meinungen und wir hatten manchmal auch
eben Interesse am gleichen an der
gleichen Position das kommt vor in der
Politik bei Wolfgang schäubleele war
nicht unterschiedliche Meinung immer
Streit sondern es war manchmal Disput er
konnte zuhören er konnte seine Meinung
ändern und man hat sich gegenseitig
befruchtet und das fand ich immer toll
an
ihm